[Music]
mike is in canada hey mike welcome to
the ramsay show
hey dave happy to be here thanks for
having me sure man what's up
uh so i recently doubled my income i
used to make uh 40 000 a year now making
80 000 grand good for you and uh
i'm starting to pay off my debt and i
had a question so i know like i'm
currently in step two i know you need to
that's snowball you need to uh
pay the smallest the largest regardless
of interest but have a credit card put
like an equal payment plan so there's
absolutely no interest on it and it's
just equalized there's like a year and a
half left in payments about 18 months
so i was wondering should i pay that off
immediately it's only about two grand
but i also have like the second bigger
loan is like a family loan for six grand
so which one should i prioritize should
i keep making the equal payments or
should i just
squash that debt out the 2k
okay you just told me you list your
payments smallest to largest
you pay minimum payments on everything
but the smallest
and you put all the money on the
smallest until it's gone regardless of
interest
you just told me like you take a
psychologist you just told me that it
feels better to just pay off your
siblings because like that's the six
grand there's a family going on right
now
is there is are they in trouble
uh no they're just nagging about it i'm
like i just want to pay it off are you
paying them payments as agreed
no no
you're not paying them anything i'm just
gonna
no it's just like okay just paid on lump
i'm sorry
do you just wanted tape and lump sum
do you have six grand to pay my lump sum
uh no like like i'm i'm in maybe step
two so all i have like in my pockets for
like 1200 so
what was the loan for
uh it's uh well i actually have two
family loans it's for student debt so i
didn't really go through a bank or i
just borrowed from family members so
i've got 30 grand in total
all to both siblings
you have 30 grand or 3 grand
i've got
6 grand for 1 sibling 24 for the other
13 total and the six grand is the
squeaky wheel
yes okay well you'll get to them when
you get to them yeah
two grams first
knock it out all right
yeah and then and then get to the
sibling because i take it you're paying
them no payments now and when you finish
off this credit card like this month
next month you're going to start sending
them what two thousand dollars a month
or a thousand dollars a month what are
you gonna send them
yeah well they live in a different
countryside i'm because i'm a cheap
bastard i'm like okay i'll just save up
and pay him a lump to avoid the wiring
fees because she's in germany on canada
wiring fees are not that high
yeah your avoidance here
yeah i'm just avoiding it i guess yeah
and here's what i do i'd sit down i'd
call my sibling and say
i'm sorry i've left you hanging here
here's what i'm gonna do here's my plan
i'm gonna pay this much every month for
this ex time and then we're gonna get
done with this thing
all the avoidance and they all just let
it pile up yeah if i was them i'd be
house on you too because it sounds like
you're just avoiding it all
make a plan with them as though they're
a creditor right yeah
and so and it's been a while how long
have they have you had this
money uh about a year and a half now
yeah okay and you didn't have good clear
terms and agreement on when you were
gonna pay it back or how you're gonna
pay it back so they made up one scenario
in their head you made up another
scenario in your head and so now we're
pissed about the scenario that doesn't
even exist
so the best thing to do is get it off
the books as fast as you can in the
meantime call now how much can you put
on debt with 80 000 a year how much can
you put on debt a month
if i like don't go out or don't do
anything yeah like what we tell you to
do yes don't go out
what would it be
i'll try not to you know no no you don't
have to try not to don't do it
didn't you watch star wars one there is
no try just do it
so
how much
all right
how much
i could put that i will put down 25
until i pay off my debt so about that
twenty five hundred dollars hey like so
so that pays off the credit card this
month next month you're gonna send
twenty five hundred dollars the next
month you're going to send 2 500
the next month you're going to pay that
sibling off and if you call them and
tell them or send them an email that
that's what's going to occur they're
going to stop whining if you follow
through on that
and
mike i'm gonna change your life are you
ready
yes okay listen to me this is this is
the way you live this is a microcosm of
your life and it stops today
you have almost fractured family
relationships
over a problem that could be solved in
90 days
that's ridiculous because you're
circling around and you're like i don't
know
solve the problem in 90 days
most of our health problems can be
solved in 90 days a great number of our
mental health challenges can be solved
in 90 days relationships can be healed
tonight if someone will just go do it
well goose if i don't go out anymore is
it worth your sister
get done with it man what dinner is
worth your sister right or who's to my
friends get it paid off and never ever
ever
not get something knocked out that's
gonna take 90 days of hard work good
grief okay that's it i'm done now we're
good oh yeah i'm glad you feel bad i'm
done now jesus christ but that's exactly
right so star wars one was
there is no try was yoda that was yoda
in one i think it was one or two i don't
i don't know i'm looking at james james
james sorry i'm not a star you're not a
star wars geek
oh
you look like he tells luke to do this
thing and they're in a swamp and he's
like lifting the oh man
we've said some things on the show that
gets the hate mail on the cards and
letters but we're about to get them yeah
we're gonna get now we got a whole two
and he said i'm getting a vote for two
i'll try to lift it i'm getting a vote
for two from the from the lobby he said
there's gotta vote for two all right
well but uh
yeah i i'm cuz i'm thinking one didn't
have that much pithiness in it
um i could be wrong but it's um
yeah i mean it's so old episode five if
you're a true nerd it was so old i was a
teenager okay that's how old one is all
right
that's
freaking old you went to the theater in
your covered wagon rocky horror picture
show and star wars brand new butterfly
how old it was
oh man so here's the thing
i think that brings up a good point
though um
our our friend our mutual friend james
clear that wrote the book atomic habits
um he talks about and craig groeschel
was talking about this another friend in
his leadership podcast the other day um
and he's speaking at the smart
conference in the fall craig is but this
idea that um
you have to be careful
biblically and psychologically what
comes out of your mouth
i'll try yep no you're not a person who
is trying to quit smoking you're a
person who
used to smoke that's right
that's a whole different set of phrasing
activate your brain
your spirit in a whole different way
that's right i am getting out of debt
and so during this time i'm going to
list the debts smallest to largest i'm
going to pay minimum payments on
everything but the little one i'm going
to attack the little one with a
vengeance i'm not going to see the
inside of a restaurant during this
period of time unless i'm working there
as my extra job
and i'm not going on vacation during
this time there is no try that's exactly
right you you i use you create a new
identity i'm a person who used to
struggle with money i don't anymore
right i'm a steward of my money period
yeah and that that is the frame with
which i decide am i going to go out math
used to intimidate me it doesn't anymore
correct i'm a person i'm a person who
does the math because it's causing me to
win at my life and oh by the way the
math is the fifth grade level
needed to build wealth you don't have to
have a calculus degree to build wealth
that's right you do not have to pass
trigonometry or geometry you don't have
to spell pythagorean theorem to become
wealthy all you've got to do is one you
don't even have to be really good at
multiplication right just long division
and
addition and a little subtraction
it's not that hard but it's but what
happens is our brains tell us this stuff
over and over and over i was the kid who
struggled in math class so i'm not good
at money or some or your mom told you
we're just not good at math in the in
the
ramsey family's not good at math well
the ramsey family's always good at math
and you took that on as an identity
right this is an identity change that's
what claire's talking about right and
that's what craig's talking about you
change your identity you go this is who
i am i'm a joyful happy
really good at math person i'm a guy
that takes hey i used to fight it i got
to go work out i got to go to work out
no no i'm a guy who takes care of my
body and that will result we're working
out isn't working out that's right
there's a cause and effect here that's
right